[Music]
how's everybody doing
Wow guys are very enthusiastic fantastic
my name is Terry Ryan and I'm a
developer advocate for Google cloud
platform and my mission today is to kind
of walk people through what is a typical
journey to taking an app that you've had
somewhere else than bringing it to
Google cloud and my focus is on virtual
machine technology so a pattern we see
from a lot of people is they they when
they first come to GCP they want to do
what they've done it elsewhere but on us
so how do you do that how do you get
started that's my goal today so if
that's what you signed up for great if
not well hopefully hopefully you'll stay
so before I get started it's really
important for me to know who everybody
in the audience is and I'll probably do
this was just a show of hands so who
here is a developer all the time okay
web developers mobile developers
back-end developers okay how many people
here do systems work I see some overlap
with the developers is it because you
love DevOps or is it because your
company won't hire more people which is
it okay anybody else any other like are
there designers or UX people UI people
all right fantastic anybody who tells
any of these other people what to do any
managers in the room okay so there's a
lot more of us in there our view so one
manager jokes fly and two I hear your
systems people could use some more
people just just I hear that from the
crowd all right so I know what jokes I
could make I know who you guys are what
are our goals our goals are to take
someone from a journey I've got an app
and I want to get it on Google cloud
platform that's my primary goal my
secondary goal is to sort of point out a
whole lot of things about GCP along the
way but that's a secondary goal so I'm
gonna fall way short on that there's a
lot of GCP that I'm not going to talk
about hopefully I'll point you in
directions where you can if you like it
you can start learning more and go that
way but just be aware that this is not
super comprehensive
okay so you have an app you have it
running someplace we usually do what we
call lift and shift where he picks
something up and just plop it on our
cloud instead of running it on your own
data centers so I want to show an app
here so I'm gonna switch over to my
laptop and this is a super super simple
app called tagger that I wrote just to
kind of its Minimum Viable Product right
it's just to show show what I'm trying
to do off here so you see you have a
bunch of tags and a bunch of kids
because you know always always get
points from the audience from showing
cute kids I'm gonna go ahead and just
show you that this is a real thing it's
running locally on my laptop but it
could also be running you know in the
data center somewhere in my own on-prem
Center so I glad eater know how to open
nothing up my sleeve I've got a real app
here running upload and there we are app
is working now
I'm gonna switch back and talk a little
bit about the architecture in slides so
very very basic simple app again written
to illustrate this stuff I've got one
single box which may or may not be the
way you want to run your stuff if you
are it's okay and then if you're not
please don't judge me too harshly so I
have a single server here and it's
running the application code it's
running the file system and it's running
the images right all of that is on one
space and I want to move this to make it
cloudy so our eventual destination with
this will be will look like this where
my database is in the cloud and my files
are in the cloud but my app still sits
on a VM which also is in the cloud but
you know it's still virtual machine I'm
not trying to get you to move to
kubernetes or orchid server lists or
anything like that well I'll talk about
those topics but I'm not we're not gonna
move to them in this in this app okay so
we talked about virtual machines on
Google cloud platform they are we call
it compute engine we have several
engines compute engine is our virtual
machines that has some properties and
some things I'm going to talk about you
can dial in how many processors you need
from one to nine
and then you can have a range of memory
based on that from point six to six out
of 24 gigs you have disks you can
install 64 terabytes of persistent disk
three terabytes of SSD and you can go up
to two hundred eight gigs of ram disk
with the memory on your system now
we have images to go with these machines
already that have operating systems
already set up but you can configure
your own and actually I'm just going to
shove that off in the interface so I'm
gonna switch to do it another demo and
you should uh-oh it was working two
seconds ago now all right it's working
all right so I want to go ahead and
create an instance I'm gonna create a
new instance that I want to run my stuff
on so I'm gonna hit what's labeled here
create instance kind of a little on the
nose so I'm gonna go ahead and create
instance when I do that I can give it a
name and I can put it in a data center
so why don't we do US West US West
because that's where we are but note we
can go all over Asia and Europe and
South America and Australia but I'll
stick to being close to here now when I
go to set up my machine there's a whole
bunch of set types of machine like
sixteen core and 32 core but one of the
cool things about our platform is that
you can actually dial in if you have a
use case where you really only need
let's say 44 processors to really do the
work you need to do your with other kind
of choices you have to go either 32 and
be under SPECT or go 64 and waste all
that money on processors you don't need
with us you can dial in exactly to what
you want and you can see exactly on the
right what the impact of those choices
are right and I got a little warning at
some there you go oh it came up I didn't
hit it right but it basically a little
warning and said hey you could probably
get a better price if you could figure
it this way which is kind of cool but
I'm gonna go and stick with our set
images because I don't want to pay that
much and then I'll go to the boot disks
with boot disk I have a whole bunch of
choices a different operating system
container OS and Red Hat and window
even yes you can do Windows on Google
cloud platform but I'm gonna go to go
ahead and keep with the defaults I'm
gonna hit select now you notice I have
another couple of options I can activate
HTTP I gonna open up the firewall I'm
not going to do it this time around but
one of the favorite things about this
interface is down at the bottom there's
this equivalent rest or command line
link so after I could figure this whole
thing I click on this and I get this
little box that says here's exactly how
to do this on the command line so I can
then configure it once in in the
interface and then take this and
automate it and use build scripts and I
don't have to write these things from
scratch
which is really helpful when we go ahead
and create this and we like to say these
spin up in tens of seconds meaning one
of my hotel room practicing this because
I'm doing it at i/o it takes like 10
seconds when I'm in front of people it
takes longer I don't know how it knows
but somehow it knows
so hopefully oh alright good it you
don't register so I'm happy it doesn't
know you're here alright so I'm gonna
hit SSH and what I do instead of having
to pull down certs to you know connect
to this VM I can do it right through
this interface right through the web
which I love for like I can travel
without my laptop as long as I get to a
browser I can I can I can take care and
manage my stuff first time you asked
this H into a box it takes a little bit
time because it is doing that manual
work used to do it's doing it you know
automatically for you so at this point
and I wouldn't worry about the text here
too much but I will blow it up a little
bit at this point what I would do is go
through and apt-get update right and
then it'll fail because I should have
stood it so I'll do so do been bang to
run the same command and there I would
go through I would do apt-get update and
then I would start rolling through and
installing software I feel like that
would strain our relationship as an
audience and speaker if I were to just
sit here and install a lamp because
that's what's running on this other box
if i sat there and installed all those
things over and over again I feel like I
would lose you so I have a solution for
that which is that I've already done
that on another machine I then taken
that machine and created it what we call
a disk image from it I said you could
use ours we
to use your own so I'm going to create a
second instance here and on this one I'm
going to open up the firewall I'm going
to open up port hdhd HTTP port and when
I go to select images instead of using
OS images I'm gonna use custom images
it's gonna take a second and you'll see
here that I have one called tagger
latest which I already built
I'll hit select and now when this app
when this app comes up it will be
running completely the whole software
stack none of my software is on there in
my app is on there but all the
supporting software I need is there so
hopefully in a second this will come up
maybe hopefully it has not identified
that you're here and when it comes up
you'll notice that I had these external
IP addresses here and some of them are
linked and some of them aren't the one I
just created wasn't like because it
didn't open up HTTP but on this one I
did so when I click on it it should go
right to the Apache TV and default page
so I've installed
I have software running on a VM it's all
set ready to go so one last thing I want
to show you before I switch back to
presenting is up here in the upper right
I've got this little like command prompt
it's another one of my favorite features
instead of having to install all the SDK
and all the stuff it takes to manage
google cloud on my laptop I can just use
cloud shell it spins up a little vm
under the covers that i don't get
charged for it's got a home directory so
i can use it over and over again i can
save scripts there but now i have a
one-way or i have access to this without
having to install all this stuff on my
computer so really helpful really really
great for trying stuff out so with that
i'm gonna switch back to presenting and
talk through a little bit of what i did
here so if you want to start doing this
you know programmatically and repeatedly
and kind of put into your build cycles
you can do all of what I did here with
g-cloud command so this one is g-cloud
compute instances create that's how I
create an instance and then I would
probably want to run commands on those
boxes so I can do that g-cloud compute
SSH virtual machine name and the command
I want to run locally
or remotely and then finally I have
files that I want to get onto those VMs
I can do that with g-cloud compute SCP
so between these three I can completely
automate the creation and configuration
of a machine repeatably and I do a lot
of this I do a lot of scripting of this
stuff because I don't want to do it by
hand
does that make mistakes so we talked
about virtual machines and disk images
so yep you can start with ours like I
did you create put all the software on
it make a disk and then save it as an
image but you can also make them from
scratch you use VirtualBox to make
images from scratch and upload them to
us networking I talked about a little
bit about that you get external IPS but
one of the things I didn't talk about is
that any you can always get an IP
address and always be ephemeral meaning
if the machine goes down when it comes
back up it'll get another IP address but
any of those IP addresses you can grab
and say make static and keep and so like
if you start fooling around with a box
and you set it to ephemeral and you're
now worried because stuff is now
depending on the IP address of this box
you can grab it hold onto it we don't
charge you for those the only time we
charge you and this is something that
members of my team just learned is we
only charge you for it if you don't use
it so if you have an IP address and it's
in you statically we don't charge you
for it it's when you park on it that we
we have like a little nominal charge as
a couple cents it's just enough to make
kind of disincentivize you from holding
on to IP addresses for a long time or
holding on to a lot of IP addresses for
a long time showed off the firewall that
you can create rules I just did the HDTV
rule which we've kind of automated but
you can create arbitrary rules and they
get applied the same way they get this
tag that gets applied to your machine
and that's what I'll that's what will
determine whether or not your firewall
is open on the machine one thing I
didn't show off is something called
cloud launcher our cloud our VMs our
images start at the software layer like
the OS layer but if you want like I
don't know like a Sandra or WordPress or
Drupal or something like that on your
machine you can use one of these and
sort of shortcut like having to do the
whole build now it's important to know
that we don't manage it once you build
it
just help you build it all right I'm
gonna take a slight detour and talk
about I talked about the cloud shell for
a second that's really important like I
said it's a little VM and you have a
home directory that follows you which is
like shove scripts in there that you use
all the time and it'll be there the next
time you go to cloud shell and it
basically means like I never have to
like while I love having my laptop I
never actually have to have it somewhere
when I might need to log in to Google
cloud platform all right we're back from
that little diversion so now let's talk
about storage right because that's the
the crux of what this app does it stores
files and it stores data I'm gonna start
with the files part of it the images so
for images we call that blob data
because I don't know that sounds gross I
guess cloud storage is the tool for that
so it's for files for videos for
pictures for unstructured documents now
there are four types and I'll talk about
them but they all have the same
interface and the metaphor is you've
seen with other cloud providers the idea
of a bucket and objects in that bucket
that's what Cloud Files store that's how
cloud storage works so we have the four
types we've got multi regional regional
cold linear line and cold line and they
all have different use cases and
different costs associated with it
long story short multi-regional is for
global data it's for you pushing the
data as close to the people they're
gonna be using it so it's for people
outside your company it's for web
presence it's for web apps it's for
mobile apps it's for long streaming
video regional in contrast is you want
to keep the data close to where it's
being used just like in global but for
this it's being used for internal
purposes so we're running data jobs and
doing big data analysis on large data
sets you want that data near the
computers are going to be doing that but
don't necessarily have to be near the
public now another thing to note here is
this because it's regional doesn't mean
it's only accessible from the region
it's in it just means that it is fastest
in that region and you can still pull
this data from other places around the
world so you're not you're not
restricted of where you can use this
data from near line and cold line or
long-term storage options therefore you
know in the in case of near line it's
for backups and long tail media stuff
that's going to be used regularly but
infrequently and for cold line it's
things like compliance
disaster recovery so if you're pulling
down data from cold line you're probably
also loading a resume in an editor just
in case right so that's sort of the
distinction we use for these now as we
go to the right the price goes down
because it's less accessible and less
easy to get to the time to first byte
for global or multi-regional versus cold
line cold line is a little bit slower
time to first byte and so accordingly
the costs go down but for near line and
cold line when you retrieve the data you
get charged for it and in this case it's
one gigabyte per I'm sorry one all those
prices were gigabyte per month this is
per gigabyte so when you pull down data
at a near line it's going to cost you a
cent per gigabyte and add a cold line
five cents per per gigabyte the idea
here is we want to encourage you like
the store stuff and hope you never need
need to use it and that's why the
pricing is set up that way they sort of
encourage that sort of use now I'm gonna
do a quick demo of cloud storage so I'm
gonna switch back to my laptop here I'm
gonna show how easy it is to sort of set
one of this up I'm gonna go ahead and
like I said it's a bucket so I'm gonna
create a bucket I'm gonna call it tagger
102 because the names have to be unique
I'm gonna just go ahead and create it
it's it's multi-regional so I'm now
creating a multi regional bucket it's
already ready for me I'm gonna upload
the files
I'm gonna take my files from here that I
already had I'm gonna upload them let's
see how our network is doing okay Wi-Fi
network is there we go alright so you'll
see I have a whole bunch of images here
now loaded in now I can't get to any of
these I mean Google clouds and CDs and
share them on Google a lot apps but I
can't look like the public can't see
them the way I enable them to the public
is I can just click this little thing
here and say oh no share publicly and
when I do that I get a public link so
even though I just uploaded it it's now
globally available and able to pull down
if I were to URL hack and change it to
one of the other images was that kid the
Ewok costume which
Ewok jpg I hit Ibaka JPEG and not there
right so you can be very granular with
what you share and what you don't share
so I'm now going to switch back to
presenting oh wait I'm not gonna switch
back it'll switch back on this and let's
talk about a little bit what I did I
wanted to upload files and you can do
that with the GS util command on the
command line that's how I do most of
this right because I don't want to
manually put all my files through a web
interface I can also share publicly
using GS util I can set up the settings
you can do them per file you can also do
them per bucket that's how I tend to do
it I share the bucket and then I try not
to have shared and non-shared stuff in
the same even though you can just saying
for me I don't want to accidentally
share something so I usually try to make
that distinction at the bucket level now
my app was writing to file storage on
the on the server
I now need it to write to cloud storage
so for that I want to use our client
libraries now our client libraries
you'll see there's a whole list of
languages they're available for if your
favorite language is not here one I
apologize - we have a REST API and it's
pretty well documented so you can you
can sort of can you can sort of do this
stuff without needing the the client
library but this applets PHP so I don't
have a problem so let's walk through
this please don't judge me for PHP I
figured it was very readable move
uploaded file source destination so
something's been uploaded to this the
server we move it to a file location to
do the same thing but point it to cloud
storage I have to pull in the storage
library and then create a storage client
and a bucket and upload to that bucket
it's a little bit more code but not
tremendously more and dropping it in was
relatively simple and painless to do so
that is client leverage so now here's
where we are we've we've carved off
images we now have our application code
in our database still together and we
need to fix that so let's talk about
databases with that I'll go to
application storage and we get the
sequel vs. no sequel and that is not
anything that I want to wade into I'm
sure we all have beliefs about sequel
vs. no sequel it's ok I'm not going to
question any of them
but I'll talk about what we have for
these two places or these two types so
we have cloud sequel which is a
traditional sequel server
it's MySQL or Postgres and it's what we
call vertically scalable you can keep
making the machine that's running on
bigger and bigger but at a certain point
when you need to scale out these don't
scale out perfectly well you can do
replica sets and we make that easy to do
but it is still just good old-fashioned
vanilla my MySQL and Postgres under the
covers we just managed the backups and
we make it easy to set up replicas and
we take a lot of the pain out of running
these machines and we also have this
other thing called cloud spanner which
like let me put in context you would
never use on this app it's just it's for
gigantic worldwide companies that have
you know very high rates of queries per
second it is not for this tagger app but
that's also available to you it has a
sequel interface it's structured data
highly available strongly consistent our
network makes that that work where we
can make those claims that it is both
those things and it's horizontally
scalable but keep in mind it is
definitely cost effective when you have
the scale for it at like this small app
it would be overkill so now let's talk
about no SQL no SQL we've got cloud
datastore in fire store I'll start with
first anybody here use firebase okay so
cloud fires store has a lot of
integration with firebase and there's a
similar product called cloud fire store
for forget the branding of it but it's
the same thing and basically it allows
you to use firebase as api's to write to
a gigantic no sequel store on the back
end it's really great when you're
writing mobile clients and web clients
that you don't want to back-end at all
you don't want application structure at
all you just basically want the
front-end app to talk directly to the
datastore
that's what cloud fire store is for
cloud datastore is more for I've got an
app that I've written that I also want
to store stuff to and that's running on
the backend and that communication would
happen between cloud datastore and the
store add your app and finally BigTable
you don't see it a lot in applications
very rarely like someone will come out
and use this for an application because
it's got very low latency but where it
really excels is Big Data jobs do you
put a whole bunch of lobs in there
and and store them and run through stuff
in that so that's plaid BigTable it's
another one that's only cost-effective
at scale so which one would should we
use well I kind of set this up so that
there is an obvious winner I'm not gonna
rewrite all my logic from sequel to Noah
to know sequel so I'm not gonna use any
of the no sequel solutions and cloud
spanner is overkill so I'm going to use
cloud sequel we've got on the next one
and I'm going to use MySQL instead of
Postgres because again I don't want to
rewrite stuff so I'm gonna do a quick
demo of this to show you what this
interface looks like I've got sequel
here I already have a database set up
but I'm gonna create a new one and
you'll see I got some options MySQL vs.
Postgres and we actually kind of help
you like what are you gonna use this for
you can use it for development for
staging for production I'm gonna use
staging because among its many features
it has this which is automatic increases
storage so when I set up my disks on the
back end it will automatically make my
disk bigger if I start to run afoul of
the the size of the disk up to 64
terabytes so I'm gonna go ahead and
configure one of these now you choose
version I can choose machine type so I
can make the Machine bigger there based
on our VM images you can't customize
them but they're there they're they kind
of fit with the VM standard images you
can choose SS th standard disk but one
of the cool things you need to know is
that if you need higher read/write
performance to your disks you need to
give bigger drives and you'll see when I
change this number over here from 20 to
200 all of a sudden I get more I ops and
disk throughput so keep that in mind you
might need to make bigger disks to get
better performance okay so I think
that's what I want to show off about
cloud sequel so I'm gonna switch back to
present mode I'm going to switch back to
present mode there we go
I'm pressing the wrong button alright
I'm all over the place alright so how do
I get my stuff into cloud sequel it's a
relatively simple I take it I upload it
to cloud storage and then from cloud
storage I ingest it into cloud sequel
which brings up something kind of
important which is
this workflow moved to cloud storage and
then pull it somewhere else is actually
pretty common you have a whole bunch of
log data you put in cloud storage ingest
it into bigquery you have images that
you want to analyze with our machine
learning api's put into cloud storage
and have them analyze it and you'll see
two tools here in the center cloud
storage is one of those that acts as a
hub the other one is something called
cloud pub/sub there's actually a really
cool demo of pub/sub in the cloud dome
in case you're you're interested but
what pops up dub does is it's a
messaging bus you say I'm a publisher
and there's a whole bunch of people who
subscribe to the channel that you
publish to you send a message a
structured piece of data that does
something and it gets navigated it gets
communicated out to all the people that
are all the all the subscribers of that
service it's very high throughput so
basically it allows you to basically
offload stuff to other pieces of the
cloud when you need to and do it with a
queueing system that's really really
robust and fast
okay let's neck way back and talk about
some common problems people have when
they start running database servers on
us so one problem and I filed a bug but
I feel like I should communicate it to
you is that when you run g-cloud sequel
to ingest the sequel you might get an
error and that error is gonna look like
this internal error and then raised the
verbosity of the g-cloud command you get
that it's a sequel error which is
helpful but not really because we kind
of knew its sequel so what you do is in
the sequel interface there's this tab
called operations and in operations we
can see that there was an error we guys
should see the line number we see all
the sequel data that we need to
troubleshoot this for this particular
error it was that I had done a my sequel
dump like you normally do but I had some
super permissions which you can't have
on cloud sequel and so it balked at that
so just a couple of things that if
you're switching over to this you might
want to know off the top of your head
before you you know head death trying to
trying to track down one of this says
now what happens if we Google clout
don't offer something that you need so
you like we have MySQL and Postgres and
our no sequel solutions but you want
Cassandra or [ __ ] or one of the other
storage solutions what do you do two
options one you could
yourself from hand the build-it-yourself
from scratch yeah
mixing metaphors or you could use cloud
launcher to build one of our existing
solutions like Cassandra Redis [ __ ]
CouchDB and a whole bunch more in each
of these cases is important to note that
we don't maintain the software for you
we maintain the OS and so like in all
the cases with compute engine I didn't
mention this earlier but we do something
called live migration so when when you
update the machine it will continue
running even through the update you'll
you'll never you'll never have downtime
because we're updating the hardware we
migrate and solve that for you so you
don't have to deal with that so in each
of these cases you get that with with
with whatever solution you build but we
won't update the software or or run
backups for you for them if we don't say
we do like we do with cloud sequel all
right so now here we are we have we have
taken our app we've moved into the
clouds we put a note of VM and then
we've offloaded database and storage to
different parts of the cloud so now I'm
free to start thinking like well since
all of the data all the state of this
application is elsewhere then I can
start making interesting decisions about
how I run this do I want to run a group
of VMs behind a load balancer to make
sure that I've always got I've always
got redundancy I can do that if I want
to go to a server list solution I can do
that if I want to go to kubernetes I can
do that and I'll talk a little bit about
how to do this with a VM so how do i
scale this system so I'm going to switch
to demo one last thing I believe and
that's going to be something we call
managed instance groups so another error
just refresh and there we go so these
take minutes to get rolling instead of
seconds so I'm not again not going to
strain our relationship and do things
that take that long in front of you but
I will kind of walk you through creating
a managed instance group so basically I
define a group and I say I want this to
be a group of tacker machines I want
them all to have tagger on it I want
all to run with the same software and so
what I do is I could say well I could
put this in single a single location or
multi so I can have these groups all
around the world I put it in a
particular zone and then I can be
managed or unmanaged managed means that
every machine is based on a template and
they look exactly the same so we can do
things like say Auto scale so all the
machines are exactly the site the same
if the CPU utilization ever gets above
60 spit up another one and then she's
been up another one until it gets down
below 60 and that it could scale down
and so I could say things like make sure
they're always three no more than ten
and scale with 60% processor utilization
which is what I have for the one that I
have there and so I can build that and
you'll see that I did here in this
interface and that so I have these three
machines and if I click through I can
see that each one of these machines is
running each one of these machines is
open to the internet and each one of
these machines is running Apache just
like I want it to so we're all good so
we're to go so the next thing I want to
do is take this and make it redundant
basically share it with the world to
share it with the world I need a load
balancer so I'm going to pull in tagger
a load balancer which i've already set
up and again this takes a little while
to go so I'm just gonna walk you through
the way it's set up it's pretty simple I
say give me a front-end it's HTTP it's
on port 80 and serve it up an IP address
and then I say from the backend serve
this instance group so this instance
group everything is open on port 80
you're you're listening on port 80
combined them and make that redundant so
once I do that I have this set up the
way it is each one of those machines is
answering calls to the internet but if I
go to this machine this IP address that
I get here it's also up and running and
so like I said these will scale all of
that scaling can happen usually within
minute to two minutes so if you start
getting a load spike we can we can scale
up load relatively quickly but not
necessarily instantaneously okay so that
is scaling out this application with a
load balancer
so with that I'm gonna switch back to
presenting and take you through a couple
more things so we talked about instance
groups right which are they can be
managed or unmanaged
why would they be on manage well maybe
you want to combine a two CPU box and a
sixty CPU box I don't know why but you
want to that's cool like no judgment
you're responsible for scaling and and
all that because we can't figure out CPU
utilization like what should we add we
don't have all any of that set up we're
not using a template so you can you can
manage that but if you use manage we can
Auto scale and we can also auto heal if
you have health checks on your on your
app and it goes down we can rebuild a VM
for you and bring it back into the
instance group now we're getting talked
about load balancers we have HTTP and
HTTPS load balancer which is equivalent
of an l7 if you're you're used to that
we also do TCP and UDP load balancing
and we have internal only that are only
accessible within your project now
that's how I scale VMs but I I do work
for Google cloud and we use the
buzzwords container and services a lot
so I felt like it was necessary to at
least talk about these how many people
here are already using like docker okay
how many people are using kubernetes
okay
all right for those of you that aren't
I'll give just a quick what is
containers at a very very high level and
watch the faces of the people that raise
their hands as they squirm and scream
through this really really
oversimplified definition containers are
basically a package that contains all
the code and runtime components to run a
particular process your app and then
there's an environment docker or
kubernetes that will trick the process
into thinking it's the only one running
on the machine and so you can do crazy
things like have multiple versions of
the same software running on the same
machine you can stack as many more
processes on a machine that you can do
VMs on the same hardware so you
basically they're there there are a lot
of a lot of efficiencies you you get
from switching to this model we have two
products that we say are our container
products on Google Cloud
there are kubernetes engine which is
managed kubernetes which if you don't
know kubernetes is basically you have
dozens or
hundreds or thousands of containers all
doing different things you want to run
them in a way that you're not managing
individual containers you put them into
a kubernetes cluster with instructions
on how to run them and it'll keep them
running whether they're a micro service
a web app or a batch job somewhere app
engine flexible is if you just want
something you have one app that you just
want to scale and it's already in a
docker container you can push it to App
Engine flexible and we will scale it for
you from one to as many instances of it
you need what is service so service is a
marketing term it is right like it's
there is a server there it's not there's
some not some beast living beyond space
and time running your server your load
for you but it describes like I think a
really important distinction a different
type of app which is you pay-as-you-go
whatever you use you pay for if you
don't use it you don't pay for it and
you don't care about the underlying
infrastructure you don't have to know
about number of servers or number of
nodes or anything we will just run it
for you as much or as little as you need
so we talk about service on Google cloud
platform we're talking about two things
I talk about cloud functions which the
unit of abstraction is a function right
and you attach that function to some
sort of event someone drops a file
somewhere into a bucket someone sends a
message to a pub sub-q you respond to it
with that simple cloud function we also
have a server solution that's app based
now it's very restricted in terms of
what you can do you can only use certain
languages you can't use third-party code
you can only use code in that language
but what you get for that restriction is
incredible scaling App Engine can scale
from zero to pretty much infinite in a
relatively short period of time I have a
demo where I will scale an app that's
cold
like I didn't use it to about 8,500 QPS
queries per second in about five minutes
and to put that in perspective 8,500 QPS
is what wikipedia gets so I'm able to go
from nothing cold to like a Wikipedia
scale application in five minutes with
App Engine but again it comes at a cost
or restricted abilities to do things so
the question is
switch over to one of these that's like
a whole talk let's like a whole separate
top of weather actually has several its
virtual machine are containers but I'll
say for this app without any context no
right like it's working where it is I'm
bringing it over someplace else I don't
necessarily want to put a lot of effort
into it lift and shift is absolutely
fine if I have plans to grow this app
bigger or to grow it with a whole bunch
of other applications maybe it might
make sense to containerize but again
that would depend on the context and if
I'm gonna have very inconsistent use
then maybe serverless would work out too
but for this particular app with no
context I'm not switching it over I'm
staying on VMs ok we've come to the end
I've taken you through a pretty good
tour of what we have here we started
here we started with a single app all
running on one machine but we ended up
here where we've we've basically taken
all the state pushed it elsewhere and we
can now grow and expand have a lot of
different options with the computing
level now there was so much I couldn't
cover
I was pretty vicious with my editing pen
because I wasn't getting under 40
minutes so I didn't talk about our ml
api's which are awesome so what you
could do with our ml API same sort of
insert in the code the way we did cloud
storage you can grab with vision API you
can take this I'm not gonna switch it
don't switch over but you'll notice
there that I have tags that I got from
cloud vision API instead of making
people do it so this app I could just
completely replace data entry on this
app with con vision if I wanted to I
think it's funny a little detail is that
it thinks that the ewok the kid the Ewok
costume is carnival carnivore in which
is kind of scary but I don't know how
he's raised I don't know
so just see it can evoke costume be
afraid but cloud vision was able to do
that for me it also picked out skin and
children and picked a whole bunch of
details from those images I didn't talk
about the API library so if you're using
any of the other Google API is like Maps
or YouTube or ads you can manage them
through here and use them in your Google
platform project with default
credentials that you don't have to set
up a lot of certs and a lot of
credentialing information you can just
run it with kind of very minimal
authentication but
surely then talk about stackdriver if
you need your lap your lobs or
monitoring and all that stuff stock
driver you can do this for you all this
stuff I talked I didn't even I didn't
give a chance to talk about we'll all
help you run in this scenario so we look
at Google cloud as a whole I talked
about the compute platform I think we
covered a lot of it
we covered storage and databases we
covered a little bit of networking we
covered a little the Tiny's a little bit
of big data in that I mentioned pub/sub
mention the machine learning api's
mentioned developer tools and mentioned
management tools but if you look at this
whole list there's a lot of missing
because there's just a lot more to the
platform so I'd ask if you have any
questions or if this is ignited anything
and you please make sure you stop by the
cloud booth there's everybody from
Google not everybody but a lot of people
from Google cloud are there and can
answer your questions and hopefully I
showed you how you can onboard and how
you can get started with Google cloud
keep in mind that if you sign up you get
a $300 free credit for 12 months that
you can use to kick the tires and
hopefully you go from here to
discovering more about what's what's on
the platform so thank you very much I've
been Terry Ryan please feel free to
heckle me on twitter at TP ryan if you
have any questions I'll be around but I
think I'm running short on time so have
a good rest of your i/o
[Music]